préoccupation aussi en russie avec un
triste record 151000 malades ducobu 19
hospitalisées selon le ministère de la
santé
le pays plus que jamais confrontés aux
variants delta la correspondance de
drague of mana moscou il sera impossible
d'atteindre le chiffre de ce sont pour
cent de vaccination dans la population
avant le tonnes initialement prévue par
les autorités a affirmé le porte parole
du kremlin dmitri peskov
bien que le produit était accessible la
dynamique de vaccination a été jusqu'ici
à un niveau assez faible la tendance
vient de changer et espère le kram 1 va
persister
écoutez évidemment nous n'arriverons pas
à vacciner 60 % de la population
nous constatons que ce n'est que cette
semaine que le nombre de personnes
souhaitant se faire vacciner a commencé
plus ou moins augmenté avant la
dynamique de vaccination était
malheureusement à un niveau faible
alors que toutes les opportunités pour
cela été créée par l'état
dieu merci actuellement de plus en plus
de citoyens font preuve de conscience
espérons donc que cette dynamique
persistera mais bien sûr il est évident
que ce niveau de vaccination ne sera pas
atteint par conséquent bien sûr les
délais seront reportés
le directeur du centre national de
recherche gamaleya concepteur du vaccin
spoutnik les alexandre gainsbourg a
quant à lui mis en garde contre le
pourcentage plus élevé des cas mortels
de kovy 19 liées à la propagation du
variant delta du virus
écoutez cette maladie est très rusé et
avoir une forme légère ne garantit pas
d'être protégé contre la maladie
parce que d'un côté elle provoque de
graves complications et de l'autre dans
un grand pourcentage des cas elles se
terminent par des formes très grave il y
à un nombre de cas qui de toute évidence
va augmenter constamment ce pourcentage
de cas graves
menant à la mort n'est pas de 1 2% mais
s'élève à 5 ou 10%
donc la vaccination est tout à fait
nécessaire en tant que moyen de
prévention contre cette maladie d'un
côté et de l'autre pour terminer le
processus épidémiologique et susciter
une immunité collective
c'est le seul moyen d'arrêter la
pandémie plus de vingt mille nouveaux
cas de corner virus ont été détectés
aujourd'hui dans 85 régions russes dont
plus de 6000 à moscou
le nombre des décès est également en
hausse et 650 morts dans le pays dans
121 dans la capitale en dernières 24
heures